pub
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
paris où il était pour trois jours
l'hôte officielle de la france a fait la
connaissance du roi de thaïlande
jeanne souverain héréditaire d'un vieux
royaume qu'on appelait le siam avant la
guerre les parisiens l'ont vu se
recueillir à l'arc de triomphe sur la
tombe du soldat inconnu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
harry a fait aussi la connaissance de la
reine de thaïlande qui a consacré une
heure à la haute couture parisienne
[Musique]
la reine syrie qui est apparu comme une
jeune femme élégant tous les thaïlandais
ajouteront à cela qu'il possède la plus
belle souveraine du monde et il est bien
des parisiens aujourd'hui qui partage
leur opinion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ambitieux d'automne le groupe des cinq
qui forment les marchands de la mode
masculine à dévoiler ses batteries et de
l'avis des connaisseurs qui assistait à
ce galop d'essai c'est une révolution
le groupe des cinq vit au vert une mode
plus classique qui garde toutefois
quelques fantaisies l'aube ouverture
dorsale molle de fous rires double
fantasy voilà pour les pardessus
[Musique]
même la fourrure triomphe avec ce
délicieux 7/8 brightman scolari poil de
chameau
qu'a dit on commet des gendarmes
la ville restant à deux boutons
seulement revers et 3 et gilet à
boutonnage déportés
et pour le soir avec les tissus à
reflets révélation de la cravate bijoux
alors avouant que cette mode a du chien
[Musique]
maintenant que celle-ci bien sûr car lui
aussi le tout-paris canin disons le tout
paris a présenté sa collection d'hiver
la collection d'été ne comportant comme
chacun sait que des colliers au milieu
des chochottes immonde un des mannequins
choisis
pauvres bêtes nous ont découvert la
ligne idéale du prêt-à-porter dans le
domaine de l'élégance à quatre pattes
est également jusqu'où peut aller
quelquefois une certaine sottise on doit
regarder avec un certain sourire
[Musique]
il paraît à la lumière de cette
présentation que la grande mode sera
bientôt pour nos bellamy d'être vêtu
comme le chien chien de sa mémé leurs
invités tout va très bien madame la
marquise
et voici longtemps que le ridicule ne
tue plus personne
suivez le boeuf tel est le conseil donné
par le panonceau que les ménagères ont
vu apparaître dans nombre de boucherie
pas dans toutes cependant il annonce la
campagne tendant à faire sinon baisser
les prix de la viande du moins à arrêter
la hausse constante depuis de nombreux
mois
ces bouchées selon le numéro de leur
chaîne basée sur la qualité de leurs
marchandises vendre leur viande selon un
barème parfaitement rigoureux et
parfaitement contrôlable
mais ça n'est pas tout car cet effort
est fait pour ce doublé d'un autre
l'éducation de l'acheteur aujourd'hui
voici ce qu on entend même s'il vous
plaît à 24 ans madame monsieur
impopulaire une autre cote s'il vous
plaît on le voit plaques portent
maintenant à albi populaire un aspect qu
un tournedos à tourner le dos résultat
toute la viande à rôtir tout le bifteck
a disparu il reste les morceaux à
braiser et le pot-au-feu et c'est là
qu'est le problème viande à bichkek
c'est l'arrière du boeuf viande à
braiser pot-au-feu c'est le devant le
devant ne se vend pas l'arrière subit
donc on sur plus de son prix le prix de
la vendus et ce gaspillage nous coûte
150 milliards par an alors il faut
apprendre son boeuf pour le manger moins
cher
suivez le boeuf
la reine elizabeth ne règne plus sur
l'afrique du sud ainsi en ont décidé en
votant pour la république les électeurs
de l'union sud-africaine
il convient de préciser que seule la
population blanche soit 3 millions
d'individus étaient conviés à participer
au référendum à l'exclusion des 11
millions de noirs
la victoire du docteur bert lord et d
afrique anders n'a finalement été
acquise qu'avec une petite majorité de
74 1580 vre
[Musique]
m
une question se pose la république
sud-africaine voudra-t-elle rester dans
le commonwealth
[Musique]
la mort héroïque sur ce sol algérien où
s'était déjà illustré son arrière grand
oncle leduc tonale du sous lieutenant
françois d'orléans deuxième fils du
comte de paris n'est qu'une mort
héroïque entre d'eau ce jeune garçon de
25 ans tué au combat à l'orée de la vie
n'est qu'un exemple entre d'autres
s'il ya derrière ce cercueil avec les
autorités de l'état une famille
douloureuse
il y a aussi tous les morts d'algérie et
toutes les familles douloureuse de
france
à bruxelles la proche du mariage royal
n'efface pas de tous les esprits la
sphère congolais est en effet les dix
mille réfugiés de l'ex congo belge se
sont emparés de la rue où ils ont
rencontré les forces de police sans
douceur
on n'avait pas vu depuis longtemps une
manifestation aussi tumultueuse
au japon la campagne électorale a
commencé tragiquement à tokyo devant
3000 personnes et les caméras de la
télévision japonaise
le leader socialiste inné giro à anouma
parlait depuis sept minutes
toutacoo bondissant des rendus publics à
tout jeune homme se précipita sur lui
l'orateur s'effondre à l'énergumène un
étudiant de 17 ans venait de le
poignarder à deux reprises son geste
avait été enregistrée par les caméras
mais seul le ralenti permet de saisir le
drame
les allemands affectionne
particulièrement ce petit jeu de la roue
mobile qui est en fait une variante très
gracieuse de la gymnastique classique
cette compétition se déroule à hanovre
l'expression faire la route quand ici
tout son sens
il faut non seulement beaucoup de grâce
mais également de la force et aussi le
sens de l' équilibre pour réaliser
d'aussi remarquables figurent
[Musique]
elle ne tombera pas rassuré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la solidarité du sexe faible n'est pas
un vain mot
des hommes aussi pratiquer ce genre de
sport mais comme ils sont plus audacieux
le roux n'est constitué que d'un seul
cercle c'est en quelque sorte une
manière assez originale de joie au
cerceau
[Musique]